trois animaux athlétique qui pourraient
participer aux jeux olympiques
1 le guépard le champion de vitesse le
guépard peut parcourir 300 mètres à plus
de 110 km par heure il est considéré
comme l'animal terrestre le plus rapide
du monde pour l'être humain le record
est détenu à l'athlète usain bolt il a
parcouru 100 m en 9 secondes soit une
vitesse de 45 kilomètres par heure c'est
deux fois et demie moins rapide que le
guépard 2 le puma le champion du saut en
hauteur la détente de cet animal peut
atteindre 5 mètres docce de tounens et
le cumin ravir sotomayor qui détient
depuis 1993 le record du saut en hauteur
avec 2 m 45 mais l'exploit le plus
impressionnant est celui de la puce dont
les sauts peuvent atteindre 34 cm de
hauteur c'est près de 340 fois sa taille
3 l'espadon voilier la formule 1 des
mers se croise on peut atteindre 120 km
par heure sous l'eau le nageur le plus
rapide du monde et l'australien kai
chalmers il détient le record en ayant
parcouru 100 m en 44 secondes une
vitesse de seulement 1000 kilomètres par
heure